ich wollte eine bestimmte freiheit ich
wollte in frieden leben ohne mir sorgen
über die spannungen in den usa zu machen
den tod die gräben zwischen den
hautfarben in ghana muss ich mir darüber
keine gedanken machen
italien hat ernst gemacht 2017 zog sie
von den usa aus nach ghana die lehrerin
tauchte ein neues amerikanisches leben
aufgewachsen ist sie in charlotte north
carolina in den südstaaten der usa war
eine von wenigen afroamerikaner innen in
der schule wie sie erzählt damals schon
wollte sie den alltäglichen rassismus
die benachteiligung hinter sich lassen
aber der wechsel von americana grafik
aber auch ein kleiner kulturschock
anfangs war ihr vieles fremd langsam
jedoch kommt sie an sagt sie vor allem
auf dem markt land sie jeden tag dazu
[Musik]
ich nehme das aber wo finde ich den
frischen fisch
[Musik]
es ist eine völlig andere erfahrung
du kannst die menschen richtig spüren
die kultur sehen die marktfrauen haben
alle verschiedene persönlichkeiten
stammen aus vielen verschiedenen
volksgruppen manchmal kannst du dich mit
ihnen verständigen manchmal nicht du
lernst alles hier wie sie geschäfte
machen du lernst die sprachen weil sie
dich dazu zwingen
du fühlst dich zu hause das ist meine
neue normalität nicht amerika sondern
ghana ist für den saal ibrahim das land
der möglichkeiten die wirtschaft ist in
den vergangenen jahren gewachsen
immer mehr wird die hauptstadt accra ihr
neues zuhause
sie hat arbeit an einer internationalen
schule gefunden am anfang haben sich
einige ihrer kolleginnen und kollegen
gewundert warum jemand aus den usa
auswandert sagte salih auch mit ihnen
musste sie erst einen gemeinsamen
rhythmus finden
unterschicht rezensiert was versucht und
es funktioniert nicht dann sage ich
siehst du lass es uns anders versuchte
die durch die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen hatten daniel graham
aber auch neue freunde gefunden
es ist etwas schwierig diese klicken
aufzubrechen
du machst eingeführt werden und dann
beharrlich sein das war wirklich hart
langsam aber sicher wird trotz der neuen
freunde und sali abraham trifft sich
auch regelmäßig mit landsleuten aus den
usa einige tausend afroamerikaner innen
sollen derzeit in keiner liebt glen
christi kam vor sieben afiaa kalia vor
dreieinhalb jahren aus ähnlichen gründen
wie in saal ii nach afrika allein schon
die tatsache dass ich einen sohn habe
und ich mir keine sorgen machen muss
dass er wegen seiner hautfarbe
erschossen wird wenn er rausgeht
ich kann gar nicht beschreiben die
richtig die entscheidung für meine
kinder und mich war hier zu sein
um ehrlich zu sein wichtig usa verlassen
weg zu sein von den us-amerikanern
meiner erfahrung als sogenannte afro
amerikanerin
das ist kein leben in dem ich mich bis
zur rente sehen
lisa lahham aber sieht nicht nur die
lage in den usa sondern vor allem auch
die chancen die ghanaer
sie plant bereits ein stück land zu
kaufen es zu bewirtschaften und so
zusätzlich zu ihrem gehalt etwas geld zu
verdienen
du kannst sehen wie die ideen in deinem
kopf realität werden
in den usa gibt es ein system und wenn
du nicht rein passt dann passt du eben
nicht in ghana aber gibt es immer einen
weg
und doch lässt sie das was auf der
anderen seite des atlantiks passiert
nicht los sie chattet mit bekannten und
verwandten sie will unbedingt per brief
an der us wahl teilnehmen
immerhin hat die demokratische
kandidatin für das amt der
vize-präsidentin kamelle herres an ihrer
uni studiert bringt menschen in eine
lage in der sie sich nicht zu hause
fühlen sie fühlen nicht dass das der
richtige platz für sie ist das ist
bedauerlich aber dann fühlen sich große
teile der bevölkerung nicht als seien
sie ein teil dieses systems
es besteht kaum ein zweifel für wen
ihrer freundin felicia mann aus den usa
will
es passiert gerade viel hier in amerika
aber ich weiß natürlich was ich tun
werde
das wissen wir doch alle
die nachrichten aus amerika etwa über
den tod von george wright spielen auch
in ghana eine rolle
auf einer trauerfeier für ihn rief die
kultur und tourismus ministerin vor
einigen wochen gab afroamerikaner innen
aktiv auf nach afrika zu kommen
meine arme sind weit geöffnet bereit
euch zu hause willkommen zu heißen
nutzt die chance und kommt nach hause
baut euch ein leben auf ihr müsst nicht
für immer bleiben wo ihr nicht gewollt
seid ihr habt die wahl afrika wartet auf
euch
dahinter steckt eine strategie im
nationaltheater hat ghanas regierung
gerade erst sein zehn jahres programm
vorgestellt durch investitionsanreize
und bessere aufenthaltsbedingungen
sollen mehr menschen bienen sandra heim
ins land geholt werden um die wirtschaft
zu starten der us-amerikaner cohen
halévy kann schon vor 25 jahren nach
ghana er ist chef einer stiftung die
menschen afrikanischer herkunft aus der
ganzen welt zusammenbringen will
afrikaner haben geholfen amerika zur
supermacht nummer eins der welt
aufzubauen zum nachteil afrika also
möchte der kontinent dass afrikaner
zurückkehren der gewinn an köpfen an
geist das wissen die erfahrung all das
wird einen unterschied machen brauchen
sali abraham hat eine organisation
namens hört collective gegründet um
afroamerikaner innen den weg nach ghana
zu ebnen
denn für sie war es die richtige
entscheidung es ist immer wieder etwas
besonderes für sie an diesen ort
zurückzukehren cape coast castle eine
jener festungen von denen die sklaven
und sklaven nach amerika verschleppt
wurden durch diese tür ohne wiederkehr
mussten sie damals gegen viele der
nachfahren besuchen diesen ort als
touristen die 32-jährige aber ist wie
sie es nennt ganz zurückgekehrt und
stolz darauf
menschen fühlen sich hier traurig andere
sind wütend ich nicht ich bin stolz dass
ich zurückgekehrt bin das ist ein beweis
der stärke der menschen die mit gewalt
fort genommen wurden wurde für einen
saal ibrahim zur tür
es gibt dieses level an freiheit in
ghana das ist so noch nicht gefühlt habe
wenn du diese erfahrung gemacht hast an
einem ort an dem du gehörst warum
solltest du dann zurückgehen
und dann erzählt sie uns noch dass sie
sich gerade verliebt hat in einen kanal
familiengründung nicht ausgeschlossen
[Musik]